okay last fluff
question has to do with cryptocurrencies
and what you see is the future of
cryptocurrencies let me read it
specifically because it came from
one of the viewers
what is the future of cryptocurrencies
this is from amjad
many ceos are buying crypto as a store
of value your thoughts on it who is
satoshi nakamoto your views on bitcoin
and proof of work algorithms versus
ethereum and proof of stake
quite a few questions when there's a
long story because we've been quite
involved in the whole crypto world um
for a variety of different reasons but
i'll tell you the thing that is most
ironic to me about the crypto world
which is back in the 1980s
you know i had this idea about
computational irreducibility the idea
that you might need to do an irreducible
amount of computation to work certain
things out
i
i have some considerable reason to
believe that
that um
uh
the um
the creator of bitcoin um
was aware of my work about computational
irreducibility
and so the thing that is kind of the
most ironic most bizarre thing is that
when i thought about computational
irreducibility in the 1980s
um
the um
i imagined it as this limitation on
science this principle about something
formal and mathematical i had no idea
that decades later there would be you
know whatever it is some number of
percentage points of the of the total
energy production of the world will be
burnt in computational irreducibility
it's an utterly bizarre it's kind of
like you you know if for somebody like
me i build theories i build tools
and then the world goes on and
eventually uses those theories and those
tools for things that are just i mean
that one was something so far out of
left field that i couldn't see coming
that it's remarkable that that that idea
of proof is completely crazy i mean it's
it's a
it to be fair it's it's a it's very
amusing and completely crazy and you
know i have certainly thought about is
there a way to do something like proof
of work that generates useful
computation and i have not yet figured
out how to do that
but with respect to cryptocurrency and
for example the question why is there
value in cryptocurrency you know i had
thought well to get value in economics
you have to actually be making something
in the real world and i thought for a
while you know we've been a lot involved
in computational contracts the idea of
expressing what would otherwise be
contracts written in legalese
in
in computational language because we
have kind of the unique computational
language that can talk about the real
world and that is therefore capable of
having you know contracts about the real
world written in it so we've done quite
a bit of work on that and i sort of
imagine my belief as a few years ago was
that when computational contracts
are the dominant form of contracts that
cryptocurrencies just become a
convenient mechanism
for
uh for sort of servicing computational
contracts
but then
the question is is there intrinsic value
in a cryptocurrency
and so this relates to the question of
well why is there intrinsic value in
anything in economics
and so that relates to what is the
foundational theory of economics
and so this is something i've been
thinking about and you know i think that
the the elementary actions in economics
are transactions
and i think that what's happening is
there this whole giant network of
transactions and why does this sound
like something what's out elsewhere well
because i think it maybe is it's
something not unlike the giant network
of updatings of this spatial hypergraph
and so on it's all these different
transactions happening in the world
and the story ends up being that what is
value value what is what is price for
example price is something related to
okay so so think about it this way i've
been using this thing last few weeks at
least you know somebody wants to buy a
cookie
the person they want to buy it from
eventually wants to rent a movie
the question is is there
in a certain world
where it's ai bots all the way down one
could imagine that they arrange this
network of transactions so the person
who wants to buy the cookie eventually
is giving value to the person who wants
to rent the movie they barter everything
so that's what happens no money is
involved it's just bought to bot
transactions
right so the question is what is money
what is price
and i think what it could be thought of
as i think i don't know if this will
really work out
that it is just like you have all these
uh sort of interactions in space and so
on and in aggregate you can think about
them as having certain gravitational
fields certain this that and the other
certain aggregate properties that is a
description of all of those microscopic
microscopic processes that are going on
so i have this slight guess
that value
and price
are associated with
sort of an aggregate version
of all these microscopic processes that
are going on and the most bizarre thing
is
that what leads those things to have a
sort of a
a robust value is computational
irreducibility so the absolutely bizarre
possibility is that the transactions
that go on an economic system
are
sort of in aggregate they are a whole
story of computational irreducibility
and the reason that they build up some
definite sort of uh sort of solid sense
of price or value
is because you sort of can't un unravel
that computational irreducibility
and so in some sense the computational
irreducibility is the source of robust
value in economics
and then that in a sense the bizarre
thing then is proof of work
is a is a crazy sort of inner bottle
version of that process so to speak
proof of work yes the proof of work is
ends up being sort of the the bottled up
version of that that idea although it's
it's a it's a poor way to to think about
that and i think that the so you know
what i'm imagining is that
that the very fact that so many people
are doing things with cryptocurrencies
is almost by definition
a proof that they have value
that is it could be the case that you
say well everybody is doing things as a
speculator which might be close to true
but even so by the time there's a
complicated enough network of
transactions that is in a sense building
you up a real value even though those
transactions don't happen to actuate
particularly in the in the quotes real
world i mean this is you know for
somebody like me who builds sort of a
model of of the universe that is in a
sense an abstract model one's asking is
there a fundamental difference between
the processes that are going on in this
purely abstract cryptocurrency and in
something that is connected to the real
world and buying cookies and so on in
the real world and the answer is i'm
increasingly coming to the belief that
there is a a notion of a store of value
that doesn't have to do with uh sort of
the details of that now as a practical
matter you know what's going to happen
with with all those cryptocurrencies you
know i have no idea you know i we've
been involved with the cryptocurrency
world so
you know at this point i am the the
proud owner of a certain amount of
cryptocurrency
and um you know it's been interesting
for me because i've i've never done
uh you know our
technology open language and mathematica
and so on get widely used by quant
finance people um but i've i've never
personally done kind of um uh you know
trading of of of those things on any
kind of serious kind of actual uh
trading screens type basis and so you
know it's kind of it's kind of a funny
thing because you know i have a company
with lots of people in it but in the end
you know we we've gotten cryptocurrency
from from a bunch of companies that we
work with and it's like what do we do
with this cryptocurrency my my long time
cfo was like you can't you know we can't
accept this cryptocurrency what the heck
are we going to do with it and you know
how do we account for it in so anyway we
finally solved those problems but but um
so i have been
i did have an amusing time a few weeks
ago when i was
was both
spending some number of hours working on
the question of why does the universe
exist
and multitasking between that and
cryptocurrency trading and that was kind
of a an interesting um interesting
personal experience
you were actively trading crypto what's
that we're just you're actively trading
crypto yes because i because we got a
bunch of cryptocurrency and we uh you
know my calculation is by the time it's
uh well the real problem was that within
my company it was like who do we
delegate the cryptocurrency trading to
and generally the the general principle
of companies is you know the ceo it
starts with the ceo and then they try
and find somebody to delegate it to and
if you know we have about 800 people but
you know if none of them was kind of
volunteering i'm going to be the
cryptocurrency trader it kind of sticks
with the ceo but but i was also just
interested to get some intuitive feeling
for it um which i think i do have now a
better feeling for um but it was just a
from a purely personal point of view the
the um the couple of days that i i
happened to spend sort of um uh uh
multitasking between figuring out why
the universe exists and figuring out um
how we should move this or that between
cryptocurrencies was uh was an
interesting um experience let's say um i
would say that the uh
uh you know we're actually
we have all the all the apparatus in
morphing language to build some very
fancy analytics for understanding what
happens with cryptocurrencies and we're
we're just starting to do that and um
you know it's so deeply analogous to
what's happening in quant quantitative
finance it's um i think it's uh
uh you know the question of of is there
going to be some store of value in the
world that isn't
gold and isn't fiat currency the answer
is presumably yes
unless governments get so freaked out
about it they managed to to to sort of
smash it um i think that the uh
you know is it good for the world though
that's a more complicated question um is
it uh um is it something where
um
you know where one can understand you
know is there some way actually it's a
good exercise you know in this theory of
economics that i'm sort of slowly
developing there are going to be analogs
of things like uh time dilation and
things like the einstein equations it's
a it's a necessary feature of this very
aggregated thing of lots of these
transactions and so then the question is
well one of the things i was joking with
as we were working on this a bit that
inflation
in economics
might turn out to be bizarrely similar
to inflation
in cosmology what do you mean that
there's an analog of the einstein field
equations in
economics
well you've got a whole space of
transactions right you've got all these
transactions happening and you've got
this question is you've got all these
transactions happening and one thing is
to say there's a global price
but actually that probably isn't true
you've got all these transactions
happening and they're all interwoven in
certain ways and you ask questions like
is that space for example arbitrage you
know you go around a loop it's like
going around a loop in space-time you go
around a loop between this transaction
and it goes in time it goes to that
transaction and so on the question of
whether there is an arbitrage
opportunity becomes a question of
whether there's curvature in this kind
of economic space
um and so that's that's the beginning
i haven't worked this theory out okay so
i don't know how it's all going to work
but that's sort of the beginning of the
story um and so that that's uh and you
know these questions about um
uh you know economic activity and and
deflection of gd6 and so on i haven't
worked all this stuff out but i have
this feeling that there may be a
correspondence and that corresponds will
be very interesting because
it allows one then to leverage both the
intuition from finance
and the intuition from physics and merge
them together i mean i have a friend
who's long well-known person who's a
who's was spent a lot of time as a
trader and for him sort of you know for
me things are functions they increase
they decrease whatever for him
everything is a put or a call and i
always have to try to remember you know
what does it mean by put a call you know
but that's just some function that is
you know some particular uh you know
payoff function as a function of price
but um uh so you know these different
intuitions that you get in different
places um have uh
like you know the notion of volatility
that we're very familiar with in in the
in the financial case you know how does
that map into fluctuations in space time
in a physics case or something i don't
know i don't know what the
correspondence will be but these are
these are things that um um
uh i think there was one other part to
that question which i perhaps now have
forgotten but but about um uh
about cryptocurrency look i think that
the thing that's interesting
proof of work algorithms versus ethereum
and proof of stake
yeah i mean look there are many
we just actually did a little conference
about um distributed consensus
which is a story of uh part of that
story that there are a whole collection
of different ways to come to consensus
about what has happened and in fact what
we realized is that uh both work i did
on cellular automata and other people
did on cellular automata back a long
time ago is deeply relevant there's this
uh
blockchain called nkn
uh that is some
nkn needless to say sort of rhymes with
nks my new kind of science thing and
their
their system is very much based on kind
of ideas from nks and it's based on
using a notion of consensus that is a
distributed consensus based on graph
cellular automata that is different from
the the sort of the proof-of-work
proof-of-stake type approach so it's a
their variety of differences that one is
a i think a rather interesting one that
uh some other people are trying to do as
well but nkn is probably the most um uh
the sort of most broadly deployed
version of that
um i think that the um uh
that's an example of of um
um
i mean
the thing that the thing to realize
about about blockchain
is computation general idea they're
different form factors they're different
workflows in which computation is used
what's happening in blockchain is
autonomous computation that's what
computational contracts will be
they are purely autonomous computation
that no human initiated it it wasn't you
know it's not it isn't just living in a
cloud it's living in a way where where
something might happen in the real world
that actuates what ends up being a giant
chain of events
in the kind of uh in the sort of
blockchain world and this kind of
autonomous computation is you know it's
kind of the ai's takeover type scenario
because it's basically you know you end
up with these giant chains of autonomous
computations and that's an interesting
situation to try to understand and there
are a lot of things that you know
something like an nft is a very
simple
kind of uh
thing about autonomous computation but
there are vastly more complex versions
of that and we're only at the very very
early stages of understanding sort of
what's possible in this in this world of
autonomous computation i think the thing
maybe i can can end with is the the
statement that um
uh you know in in just as
all these um all these sort of
interactions
in between atoms of space are kind of
what knit together the structure of
space
i think these transactions and economics
are what kind of knit together the
economic system and lead to sort of
coherence in things like prices and
economic systems and it's kind of
interesting to see
uh what um you know when you have a a
fork in a blockchain it's like an event
horizon
in uh in physical space time and uh and
when you have you know these closed uh
closed countries and so on that's
another kind of event horizon type thing
um analogous to what happens in physical
space time but these are these are
things i'm i'm just um
we're just starting to explore hopefully
i don't know how long it'll be next few
months or something i'm i'm you know for
me it's always some uh
it's a crazy thing because you know i
work in these different fields and
something like economics i've sort of
paid attention to it for decades but i
don't really know it in great detail
and um uh here i am thinking about sort
of reforming the foundations of this
field
and um it's a scary thing because it's
kind of like how much of the field
should i really know if i start knowing
too many of the details i'm already sunk
in the mud you know it's very hard to
think you know to stick your head out of
the mud so to speak because you're
already oh but i know that it's you know
marginal utility of this and that the
other but at the same time you need to
familiarize yourself so how do you
strike that balance yeah well it's a
challenge right and i'm i'm for
economics i'm i i keep on um
uh sort of poking away and i you know i
have friends who are economists and i
talk to them a bit and and you know i'm
still at the stage with economics where
where everybody tells me something i
didn't know already eventually in most
fields that i work on there comes this
moment where most things that i hear
about are things that i can readily fit
in to something i already know and and
i'm still still on the still on the the
upward curve with economics but it
always helps me with that understanding
field particularly one as complicated as
economics to have my own kind of theory
about it because then as i learn new
things i have at least a chance to fit
them in to just to a framework that i've
already built